Have you ever had that
experience?
You know, a voice you really
trust, maybe from a show you
listen to all the time,
something comforting and
familiar and it's just always
there, part of your routine,
like family, almost.
But then, maybe slowly, maybe
almost so you don't notice at
first that voice starts to feel
different.
The tone shifts.
Maybe.
Exactly.
The message lands differently
and suddenly you're sort of left
wondering, wait, what happened
here?
What changed in this
relationship I thought I had?
Well, that kind of feeling, that
really personal journey is what
we're exploring today.
We're doing a deep dive into
this, this really powerful piece
from a long time listener,
someone who feels that a major
public media institution, NPR
specifically, has just
fundamentally changed its tone,
its purpose.
Everything.
Yeah.
The source we're digging into is
an essay called Goodbye to the
Voice in My Kitchen, How NPR and
Public Media Lost me.
And it really reads like, well,
the author calls it a eulogy for
a media outlet That was for him,
Dukely trusted, a real
companion.
So our goal today is to unpack
this specific story, this
heartfelt perspective.
We want to understand the shifts
the author perceives and maybe
think a little about what these
kinds of perceptions mean for,
well, for all of us and our own
relationships with the media we
consume.
OK, So let's start at the
beginning.
Let's unpack this.
To really get the weight of
this, you have to understand
where the author's coming from.
This connection with NPR, it
wasn't casual.
It goes way back.
He was born in 1970, which is
basically right when NPR was
starting up, becoming this, you
know, defining voice.
He talks about growing up in
Hawaii, hearing NPR's warm tones
wafting through our home.
And he has these really specific
memories.
Garrison Kyler's Lake Wobegon,
You know, Click and Clack
talking about cars.
Car Talk.
Right.
And even like holiday science
specials, Christmas, Passover,
Easter, Ramadan, he mentions all
of them.
And he makes this point.
He says this wasn't politics, it
was affection.
It was a cultural education
steeped in the kind of secular
liberal humanism.
Elite, yes, but benevolent.
It was MBR and it raised me.
That's a pretty strong
statement.
It really is.
I mean, that depth, that kind of
ritualistic connection, it just
shows how media can be more than
just news, right?
It becomes part of your life,
your identity.
He calls himself an NPR lifer,
even a Wham U 88.5 hag, which is
the DC station.
He says he literally scheduled
his day around Morning Edition,
Kojo and Anamdi and Diane Rehm.
So yeah, definitely not just
background noise.
It was integral.
And it stayed with him through
college, different apartments.
He even took it overseas, lived
in Berlin for a while, he says,
and would tune into NPR Berlin
there.
Wow.
But even then, whammy you back
in DC?
That was still the voice in my
kitchen, in my car, in my
shower.
Hmm.
It's, it's quite a picture of
loyalty.
Makes you think about your own
media habits, doesn't it?
Those constants.
Yeah, for me, I remember certain
late night radio hosts growing
up, just always on.
What about you?
Any media presence that's been
that consistent?
Oh, absolutely, yeah.
For me, it was probably certain
local radio guys during my
commute, you know, felt like
they were talking right to me
day after day.
It's a good question for you
listening to what's been that
consistent media companion in
your life?
Because that deep connection,
that history, is exactly why the
shift he describes feels so
significant to him.
He puts it very bluntly.
And then slowly, and then all at
once.
It wasn't.
That's Stark.
It is.
And then he draws this contrast,
the NPR he remembers versus what
he feels it is now.
So the old NPR, as he calls it.
He describes it as literate,
calm, inquisitive, OK, liberal,
yes, but with warmth and
restraint.
Use this great phrase, elitist
in tone, but in that kind aunt
with a Sherry glass way.
I can picture that.
Yeah, and he felt like back then
they weren't trying to
radicalize me.
They were trying to Orient me,
teach me, show him what serious,
open hearted discussion sounded
like.
He talks about there being space
for self doubt, space for
disagreement.
This NPR had curiosity.
It had affection and its
storytelling, faith in
listeners, even in people
disagreed with.
OK, so that's the before and the
after his perception of the new
NPR.
The very different picture,
yeah.
Sounds like it.
He says now it's grievance, it's
rigidity, it's constant moral
panic.
Whoa, heavy words.
Yeah, NPR stopped modeling
virtue and started enforcing
dogma.
He feels what was lightly worn
elitism has hardened into
activist certainty.
And maybe the core of it is
this.
It's no longer a place to hear
from others.
It's a place to be told what to
think.
If you step back and look at the
bigger picture here, this isn't
just one person's feeling, is
it?
He's describing what he sees as
a transformation of an
institution's whole identity,
its relationship with its
audience.
And that really raises a tough
question.
How does any media outlet,
especially one with a public
mission, balance its own values
with how it's perceived its role
in public discourse?
It's a critical question, and
the author's experience offers,
well, one potential answer
right.
He seems to suggest that when an
institution shifts from, say,
orientation to enforcement, it
risks pushing away even its most
devoted followers.
That disconnect.
Between intent and perception.
Exactly.
Which leads us to a really
interesting part of his
argument.
This theory he has, He lays up
this idea, this theory about
what happened after 2016.
He thinks NPR and maybe a lot of
similar media made this huge
bet.
Yeah, high stakes gamble.
He says they basically thought
Trump was a mistake, right?
And that if they could just yell
loud enough, report hard enough,
emote vigorously enough, shame
relentlessly enough, he would be
swept away in 2020 and never
heard from again.
OK.
And his analysis of that bet?
Well, he says, quite simply,
that didn't happen, right?
He goes on to say that when
Trump won again in 2024, and he
lists it all, after 34 felony
convictions, after sexual
assault accusations, after $500
million in judgments and being
painted as a literal fascist,
the reaction from places like
NPR, in his view, was
incomprehension.
They just couldn't grasp it.
And why not, According to him?
He suggests NPR didn't account
for how many Americans saw the
media as the corrupt system, and
Trump is the person standing up
to it.
He quotes that line.
They're not coming for me,
They're coming for you.
I'm just in the way.
And the author argues that line
wasn't a punch line.
It was a lifeline for a lot of
people.
So his conclusion on this is
pretty stark.
He says Trump's victory wasn't a
bug in the system.
He is the system now because the
system broke.
The grievances Trump channels,
he argues, are real if voters
don't see him as a savior, but
as a well as a middle finger.
A protest vote, essentially.
Right.
And he says NPR never learned
that it tried to win this race
by going all out, betting it
could outlast populism without,
as he puts it, breaking its own
legs.
But he.
Thinks it did break its own
legs.
Yeah, it collapsed under its own
moral urgency.
That's his take.
It's certainly a provocative
analysis.
This idea that a media outlet
may be pursuing what it sees as
truth or justice could actually
misread the very public it's
trying to reach or alienate
parts of it.
It's a powerful thought about
the potential pitfalls when
media is perceived as taking
sides too strongly.
And he builds on that, this idea
of alienation, of misreading the
room, so to speak.
Yeah, he believes today's NPR,
in his view, isn't broadcasting
to America.
It's broadcasting about America
to a curated subset of America.
Talking to the choir,
essentially.
That's the feeling he gets.
He describes it as becoming self
referential, self soothing and
ironically anti democratic in
tone.
Why anti democratic?
Because he says it no longer
believes in persuasion, only in
purity.
And he points to specific
examples shows he used to love.
Like which ones?
Well, on the media, he says,
used to be his favorite.
Now he feels it's
indistinguishable from strategy
sessions for political
activists.
He feels 1A has lost its
gentleness.
He does give a shout out to
Latino USA as one of the few
exceptions he feels to this
rigid ideological monoculture.
OK.
And Weekend Edition with Scott
Simon seems to be the last
thread connecting him to that
older spirit.
His last appointment, he calls.
It you know, what really strikes
me here is how personal the
sense of loss is beyond just the
news or politics, he says.
I miss the music segments.
I miss the bluegrass.
I miss the Irish folk hour.
Yeah, that cultural element.
Exactly.
I miss storytelling that
included bachelor farmers and
Midwestern eccentrics and
Appalachian poets, things that
felt broader, maybe less overtly
political.
Right.
He contrasts that with what he
hears now.
Now it's all frame breaking
political theater.
It really makes you think about
what else we get from media
besides just information,
doesn't it?
That sense of cultural
connection, of belonging, and
what happens when that feels
like it's gone.
So given all this, this feeling
of change, of loss, where does
he go?
What does his media diet look
like?
Post NPR.
It's pretty interesting.
He says he never got into Rogan,
which is maybe what some might
expect, right?
Instead, he listens to a real
mix.
Now, podcasts, Yeah, but things
like long form interviews,
strange spiritual programs.
Coast to coast.
AM Archives.
Coast to coast AM OK, that's a
different vibe.
Totally.
And he explains what he's
looking for.
He says he craves escape but
clarifies not disinformation,
not extremism, just non
weaponized air.
Non weaponized air.
That's a powerful phrase.
Isn't it?
He continues.
Just voices that don't make me
feel like I'm a bad person for
breathing.
And this search, this desire for
something different in tone, led
him to a really surprising place
for his morning routine.
Instead of Morning Edition, he
wakes up with a show called Your
Morning Show with Mike Digiorno.
OK.
And who is Mike Digiorno?
He identifies him as a right
wing partisan host.
But here's the twist.
He finds him warm.
He's funny, He's human, He
laughs, He doesn't scold.
Interesting.
And then he drops this line.
Digiorno reminds me more of old
NPR than NPR does.
Followed by and that's the
saddest sentence I've ever had
to write.
Wow, that really underscores his
point, doesn't it?
That for him at least, it's not
strictly about the politics
matching his own.
It's about the tone, the
experience.
He makes similar points about
late night TV too, right?
He does.
He mentions Gutfeld on Fox News,
calls it dumb, but says that's
the point.
It doesn't treat the audience
like an HR liability.
He says he prefers Graham Norton
Show unserious, apolitical and
fun over Stephen Colbert, who he
feels turned into a priest for
the Church of Perpetual Outrage.
So again, seeking escape,
seeking a different kind of
energy, maybe less intense, less
judge, mental.
That seems to be the common
thread, how the delivery and the
perceived attitude towards the
audience can matter as much or
even more for him now than the
ideological alignment.
It's a fascinating reflection on
how tone can sometimes cut
across political divides for
listeners, which, again, makes
you think about your own choices
when you're looking for new
things to listen to or watch.
What qualities are you looking
for?
What draws you in?
You know, towards the end, he
really drives home just how much
this connection meant by talking
about who he is.
He says, basically, if you drew
a profile sketch of the kind of
listener NPR and PDS were made
for, I'm it.
Yeah.
I should have been a lifetime
member.
I should have paid a tithe to
public broadcasting until he was
85 years old.
He's painting himself as the
ideal audience member they
seemingly lost.
And he details that engagement,
doesn't he?
Being a Diane REM fanboy,
donating money, getting his
friends to listen, telling
people they had to listen to
Kojo, he says.
And this is really quite
poignant.
I wasn't just a listener, I was
their choir.
You feel the depth of that past
investment.
Absolutely, which makes his
final words His concluding
lament hits so hard, he says.
I miss NPR, I miss the voice in
my kitchen.
I miss the feeling of waking up
in a country where the smartest
people in the room still loved
it even while they tried to
improve it.
That's a powerful sense of
nostalgia and maybe
disillusionment.
And the essay closes with that
really strong statement.
That voice is gone now and I'm
still grieving.
Followed by If they've lost me,
they've lost the plot.
It transforms it from just an
opinion piece into this
expression of profound personal
loss for something that was
clearly a cultural anchor in his
life.
It really does.
It frames the whole thing around
this idea that media consumption
for some isn't just
transactional, it's relational.
And when that relationship
breaks down, it hurts.
So yeah, think about this whole
story.
What does it really mean for how
we engage with media now?
Well.
We've definitely walked through
a very personal, very emotional
journey here.
One person's relationship with
the big media institution.
It's a narrative about comfort,
deep action and this perception
of change, maybe radicalization
in his eyes and ultimately,
yeah, this real sense of loss.
And I think it's important to
remember this account isn't
necessarily about establishing
objective right or wrong.
It's about perception, it's
about expectation, and it's
definitely about the shifting
media landscape we're all
navigating.
It really pushes us to think
about how media outlets,
whatever their actual intent
might be, are ultimately
received by their audience.
What happens when that reception
leads to this kind of
fundamental disconnect we heard
about today?
It really does.
And maybe it leaves us and you
listening with a big question to
chew on as media keeps changing,
as news sources perhaps become
more polarized or niche, and as
we all try to find our own non
weaponized air, whatever that
means to each of us.
Is it even possible anymore for
one single media voice, like
maybe NPR once was, for this
author to serve a really broad,
diverse audience without
inevitably alienating some of
its original base?
Or are we just moving towards a
future where we all curate our
own much more fractured, more
niche media diets?
Less common ground maybe?
Something to think about.